now before I get into my review for Tomb
Raider I want to tell you guys really
quickly about some guys that I really
enjoy who are also really good at video
game reviews and movie reviews you guys
have probably heard of pretty much it I
love these guys
they're awesome check out this brief
little clip they made for us do you like
movies video games not yet do you like
movies well you're in luck because we
talk about movies and we also talk about
that was your cue and we also talk about
oh sorry I get the phone call and we
also talk about and we also talk about
dog we review movies we review
videogames and every Friday we discuss
the latest in video games and movies and
comics of TV shows please just subscribe
if you haven't checked out pretty much
it I strongly suggest you do so I put an
annotation for them I love these guys
Jake is great at video games and Mike
and Eric and Jake are just they're
hilarious everyone on that channel is
great go check them out so I grew up
with the Tomb Raider games and even the
Tomb Raider movies as well yes there's
something a little bit guilty pleasure
like about those movies with Angelina
Jolie running around in those tight
outfits not too hard to look at but a
lot of the earlier games for PlayStation
1 were really good some of the ones for
ps2 weren't as great and even some of
the newer ones we're alright but they
didn't really have the same richness as
those first ones on the ps1 did this
game has been hyped as a complete reboot
of the Tomb Raider games Laura Croft as
a character this is her first adventure
really she's on a ship that gets
shipwrecked on this island and she has
to learn to hunt and kill to survive and
we get to watch her as a character
blossom into the eventual Laura Croft
that we know I was really pumped for
this game because all the things I heard
about it and just how beautiful all the
previews I saw looked and I was really
excited to play this game and I'm really
happy to say that this is actually my
favorite game that I've played so far
this year this game was fantastic I
literally put it in and barely could
stop playing it for like two days and I
beat it in two days not because it's a
short game but because I couldn't put it
down
it was so immersive it looked so
beautiful the graphics were amazing and
the voice acting was fantastic this game
we really get to see Laura Croft as a
character mature and develop she
afraid the first time she encounters
violence the first time she's forced to
kill someone she actually breaks down
and cries this game is brilliant I loved
every second of it to see this character
that were so used to being a super
heroine of sorts actually reacting in a
human way to these very personal things
that are happening to her actually
frightened and scared by her environment
by the wolves and by the killers that
are all around her was just euphoric for
me as a gamer to be able to experience
such a well-known character actually get
entirely new look and feel and for it to
actually work and that was so
invigorating to play the gameplay and
the controls just feel seamless with my
hand - what happens on the screen I
absolutely adored the way this game felt
the way her character animations moved
the climbing animations were fantastic
the fighting and combat animations were
great the aiming and the weaponry
everything was just so well done this
game was meticulously crafted there are
a few issues I had with the game one of
the biggest ones that I heard a lot of
critics saying that I do kind of agree
with but also disagree with is that
Laura's transformation from scared
adventurer to killer is a little bit too
jarring like she's really afraid at
first and then all of a sudden she is
like just killing people left and right
in the game she actually does comment
how shocked she is how easy it is to
kill someone after she gets used to
doing it and so for that reason I like
that they did address that there's
moments where she actually says to
herself what am I doing here and I like
that because they showed the character
questioning the things that she was
doing and the sound for the game is
fantastic Camilla Luddington as the
voice of Laura is some of the best voice
acting I've heard in a game also the
score by Jason Graves who also did the
dead space games really great score the
graphics are beautiful once again like
dead space I found myself actually
stopping and tilting the camera around
just to look at the environments it just
it all looks beautiful as I said the
control is just about flawless there
really are hardly any problems that I
had with this game it truly is one of
the funnest game experiences that I've
had so far this year this one had really
dark moments - like where she would go
underground and there was this cult
thing it was kind of like Resident Evil
4 combined with temple of
doom it was some pretty dark stuff
there's one scene where she actually
falls in like this giant pool of blood
and she is forced to then walk around
this area just drenched in blood and it
was so visceral the way that look to see
this girl shaking and almost the verge
of tears but also being really strong
and brave in that moment it's been a
while since I've played a game where I
felt that into the main character that I
was like just playing the game just to
see where that character went it was
like the first time I played in Metal
Gear Solid and I was so invested in
Solid Snake's character that I just sat
there playing that game until I beat it
and it's the same with this game I was
so into her character because they
developed her so well and she was such a
vulnerable hero we need more of that in
action movies nowadays heroes that can
actually get hurt
that are frightened by the encounters
they have with things so we can relate
to them more and I felt that in this
game all-in-all Tomb Raider is a
near-flawless game that I barely stopped
before beating it I adored this game and
I can't wait to see what else these
developers bring I'm going to give Tomb
Raider and 9.5 out of 10 if you are a
fan of the original games please
definitely play this one it is well
worth your time even if you're not a fan
I would say this game would make you one
go out and play Tomb Raider thanks a lot
for watching guys and as always if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes